[Music]
5 54 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy how about some weekend
ramp closures where the 95 meets the
northern 215 beltway let's go
centennial bowling
all right nevada department of
transportation crews are going to be
shifting lanes to get ready for some of
the remaining work on the centennial
bowl project
east of u.s 95 and to do that well
they're going to be closing some ramps
this weekend from nine
sunday night and scheduled to run until
a five monday morning
first is that flyover amp from the
westbound 215 that takes you to the
south 95.
they'll also be closing down the exit
ramp from the north 95 to get on to
buffalo
that ramp was closed last night into
this morning as was that wreck we've
been talking about from the north 95 to
the east 215.
now all of this information and a whole
lot more is on our website
8newsnow.com just click traffic and then
driving you crazy
please buckle up drive carefully and put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com